so Jessie J now because it is award
season Grammys on the way you're
nominated for coming so do in the music
industry is it the same what do you go
out and kind of go well just sing the
song everywhere I go singing the same
song when you're having to promote it at
the time yeah
honestly it's Billy it's how the
audience makes you feel yeah you know I
just did the Jingle Ball tour across the
whole of America and the reaction to
bangbang was just so overwhelming every
show it kind of gives you a whole but
you sometimes fill the audience when you
sing price tag now like is that money
money song okay 80 in Las Vegas with a
purple bag I guess you just sing it a
lot but also if you go into acting
Harvey she's chatshow gold Jessie J cuz
she's got party tricks going yes she
does does not that good I mean it you
know ping-pong or anything but the
Grammy would be yours but no but you can
do a thing where you can couldn't like I
haven't heard this so you sing with your
mouth closed
but can we still hear you well when I
was younger I actually did an audition I
do dishes all the time and I was asked
what I could do and I discovered when I
was little that I could pretend I was in
a box
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
see what do me to sing sing bang yes in
bebo campaigning in America
[Applause]
judi dench unbuckles her pants and on
her bum as you say yes JD loves HW he
said I put your name on my ass there's a
beach wedding I think this is they would
get married on the beach wear a hideous
murder took place that's what they
memory